it's 2023 and people are more confused
about nutrition than ever it's almost
like we know too much and what we think
we know is always changing vegan versus
carnivore saturated fat versus
anti-nutrients fasting versus protein
Rich breakfast it's all confusing as and
I know you've got big questions because
I see them constantly popping up in my
comment section and DMS and while I
would love to answer every single one
individually I thought it's best we
start with some of the Heavy Hitters so
today I'm going to be answering some of
the top weight loss related search
queries on Google to help you cut
through the noise hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
most Googled questions about dieting and
weight loss and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer we will be specifically
covering weight loss related content
today so please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and guys if you're not already
subscribed help a girl out here hit that
subscribe button and follow me over on
Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen alrighty let's jump in with
question number one is fasting better
than dieting in short no if we assume
that fasting is specifically for weight
loss purposes than it is by definition a
diet oh my God both scenarios may result
in weight loss because of a calorie
deficit they just kind of restrict
calories at different times in the day
or in different ways the only way that
fasting will result in weight loss is if
it contributes to a calorie deficit and
if it does research suggests that you
could achieve weight loss at more or
less the same rate as a calorie
restricted diet that doesn't limit your
eating window in fact one study
comparing fasting and continuous calorie
restriction found that both groups had
the same caloric deficit and no
difference in weight loss so even though
technically there's no caloric or food
restriction built into fasting and you
can theoretically eat whatever or
however much you want it usually results
in a calorie deficit because we're just
not great at making up for calories lost
when we skip meals now I know a lot of
proponents of fasting claim that it's
better for fat loss as it may help to
use up some fat stores for energy
especially when paired with exercise
however research shows that there really
isn't a difference in weight loss
between fasted and non-faceted exercise
in other words regardless of what time
of day you choose to exercise and the
amount of food in the tank or not in the
tank the amount of calories expended is
ultimately equal bottom line weight loss
comes down to a calorie deficit not the
amount of fat that's burned so whether
you're contemplating weight loss from
fasting or from another form of dieting
it should be a choice that is
sustainable for you in the long term all
right question number two can weight
loss affect your period in certain cases
absolutely the female reproductive
system is very sensitive to energy
imbalances so when we lose too much
weight too quickly or we don't eat
enough calories for what our body needs
or we over exercise it can potentially
disrupt our reproductive hormones
basically what's happening is that we
put ourselves into a chronic state of
low energy availability so there's just
not enough energy available to allocate
to other bodily functions which can put
a hamper on our reproductive hormones
and increase the risk of menstrual
dysfunction we also know that body fat
is essential for the production of
estrogen so when our body fat percentage
drops too low our bodies stop producing
enough estrogen to support menstruation
that said a very high body fat
percentage can also implicate estrogen
levels and negatively impact
menstruation so when it comes to weight
loss specifically we really want to be
mindful of not losing too much weight
too quickly and making sure that we're
eating enough calories to support not
only our General Nutrition and energy
needs but also our reproductive function
as well moving on to question number
three is it pointless to exercise
without dieting abso freaking lutely not
now I assume this question is in the
context of weight loss and the query is
whether exercise does anything to help
you lose weight if you're not also
restricting your food in other words can
you out exercise a high calorie diet and
and still lose weight and if that's the
question the answer is yes technically
but unless you're Michael Phelps it's
unlikely
see you later
we know that weight loss comes down to a
calorie deficit so theoretically yes if
you're burning a ton of calories working
out then it could create a great enough
calorie deficit to result in weight loss
but we also know in real life exercise
isn't that effective for weight loss our
caloric intake is made up 100 of the
food we eat but physical activity only
makes up about 10 to 30 percent of our
caloric expenditure and only a small
subset of that is our intentional
exercise our body also has a ton of
compensatory mechanisms in place to
conserve energy and maintain energy
balance so for example we tend to eat
more after exercise and we tend to
unconsciously move less doing basic acts
of living all that said is it pointless
to exercise without dieting no God
exercise has a myriad of benefits that
are way more significant than weight
loss it can can improve mood energy
levels cognition Sleep Quality
regularity bone health and even blood
markers like cholesterol and blood
pressure so we really need to Rebrand
exercise for health not as something we
do to change our weight all right
question number four does sleeping help
you lose weight it might albeit
indirectly
so getting enough quality sleep is
essential for regulating our hunger and
fullness hormones which is why poor
sleep is often associated with increase
in appetite cravings and food intake in
fact one review found that folks who are
sleep deprived ate an additional
385 calories a day we even have some
evidence that the reward centers in the
brain are more stimulated when we're
sleep deprived which prompts us to lead
towards more high calorie foods not to
mention poor sleep can increase our
stress hormone cortisol which is also
been associated with weight retention
and increased appetite and we can't
forget the role of sleep on exercise the
more rested you are the more energized
you'll be to put the most into your
workouts and know about you guys but
doing a boot camp class is the last
thing I want to do when I've underslept
so in short while sleep may not help you
directly lose weight per se at least not
without a calorie deficit not getting
enough sleep May sabotage your goals by
dysregulating your appetite eating
habits and exercise regimen question
number five do carbs make you gain
weight oh this is a good one but the
short answer is no no they do not I know
that dye culture loves to hate on carbs
and make them like Public Enemy Number
One but carbs can not only support your
weight loss goals but also optimize your
nutrition for one we get carbs from
almost every food group except for meat
and oil so this includes fruit veggies
legumes whole grains and dairy and
obviously there's a ton of variability
here in terms of how many carbs a
certain food might contain but if we
completely cut out carbs we're also
eliminating a ton of really nutritious
food options which can feel really
restrictive and unsustainable for most
people it's also worth noting that fiber
largely comes from carb-based foods and
fiber not only supports our gut health
but also helps us feel Fuller for longer
which can help to support weight loss
and weight maintenance so again when we
cut out carbs we're also limiting our
fiber intake and its Associated gut
health and satiety benefits a lot of
people experience immediate weight loss
when they go low carb because of the
initial drop in water weight when you
deplete your glycogen stores but water
weight isn't fat what and when we look
at the data comparing low carb diets to
low fat diets we don't see any major
weight loss differences in other words
weight loss comes down to what is the
most sustainable and enjoyable way for
you to create a calorie deficit so if
you love your carbs too my top weight
loss tip here is to dress up any naked
carbs by adding a source of protein fat
and fiber and aiming for more high fiber
carbs whenever possible so for example
if you love pasta maybe try to mix in
some chicken a generous portion of
veggies and some cheese for fat and
flavor so yes you can have your cake and
eat it too and question number six can I
lose weight without dieting so this is a
tricky one to answer because it comes
down to your definition of dieting I am
assuming dieting in this context means
calorie or food restriction and we
really can't change the law of
thermodynamics ultimately if you want to
lose weight you need to create a calorie
deficit some way somehow usually this
means a diet is at least part of the
equation the challenge most folks rent
into is that constantly focusing on what
you need to remove from your diet can
put you into a scarcity mentality which
often results in a restrict binge repent
repeat cycle it's really hard to
maintain a way of eating when you're
constantly obsessing over what you can't
have and this is why I really prefer to
shift the focus away from denial and
restriction and more towards an additive
approach to eating well I actually have
a whole video on sustainable weight loss
tips which you can watch right here so
if you want the full in-depth breakdown
I highly recommend checking it out but
in short I like to think about what you
can add to your meals and snacks to make
them both satiating and satisfying to
take you from scarcity mentality to a
world of abundance this is where my
Hunger crushing combo comes into play by
adding a source of fiber protein and
healthy fats to meals and snacks all of
which are inherently very satiating we
naturally start to Edge out some of the
less satiating less nutritious Foods we
basically get more nutrition for our
calorie buck and because our mindset is
in a place of abundance not scarcity and
we're allowing ourselves foods that we
actually love we no longer feel the need
to rebel and overeat it turns your crash
weight loss diet into a lifestyle that
you can actually sustain long term
remember folks losing weight is a
marathon not a Sprint and despite what
dye culture would tell us we actually
want it to be slow and steady to
increase the likelihood of keeping that
weight off everyone's weight loss
Journeys are going to be unique and I'm
sure all of your questions related to
weight loss are unique as well so if you
have access please speak to a registered
dietitians about your needs rather than
relying on Google for advice and on that
note I hope you guys like this video if
you did please give it the thumbs up
help me out here leave a comment below
to let me know what you guys would like
me to talk about next what are your big
burning questions subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]